[Music]
in today's news we have gathered some
exciting info for you our topics this
week are a new Harry Potter movie the
official title of the Godzilla vs Kong
sequel in the upcoming Indiana Jones 5
trailer also find out how the upcoming
Penguin series links to the Batman 2 and
what Margot Robbie's departure from
Pirates of the Caribbean might have to
do with Johnny Depp enjoy our new video
this week there was new information
regarding the upcoming Penguin series
from DC after Colin Farrell's role as
the villain got a lot of positive
feedback the penguin will soon get his
own series at HBO Max not a lot is
really known yet which is why it's all
the more pleasing that HBO max official
Sarah Aubry has revealed a couple of
details about the DC EU project
according to her the penguin will be
directly connected to the Batman and
will be set between the movie and its
sequel in addition the series will serve
as a sort of transition between the two
movies and will certainly include a few
references to the Batman 2. the main
focus will be on Oswald cobblepot AKA
penguin and his life as a criminal
mastermind so contrary to previous
speculation the series will not be an
origin story but a conventional spin-off
incidentally the Batman director Matt
Reeves is also producing the series and
is likely to be interested in building a
bridge between the Batman and the Batman
2 that makes sense in terms of plot the
series will be directed by mayor of Town
director Craig zobel with the script
coming from Agents of Shield author
Lauren lafrank sadly Sarah Aubry could
not comment on a possible release date
yet so we still need to be patient a
little longer
the play Harry Potter and the cursed
child has performed worldwide since
2016. the story takes place 19 years
after the events of Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows and was actually
supposed to be brought to the big screen
however the reality of recent years
looked different and so the idea was
scrapped under the management of the new
Warner Brothers Discovery Chief David
zazlov Matt will now change the
adaptation of the play would fit very
well into the new strategy of the
company which wants to promote more of
its in-house Brands and focus on quality
over quantity in the future as the
direct reports the film adaptation of
the stage play is being tackled by
zazlab and producers Michael Deluca and
Pam Abdi unlike the books the story is
not the work of JK Rowling directly but
of screenwriter Jack Thorne who
premiered the play in London in 2016.
nevertheless zazlab is aiming for a
strong collaboration with Harry Potter
Creator Rowling who in previous years
however has been rather averse to
adapting the play into a film her
planned involvement in the movie
adaptation is sure to attract some fans
but there is no official confirmation
yet the plot of Harry Potter and the
cursed child is about Harry and Ginny's
son Albus Severus Potter now that the
hero of the fantasy novel and movie
series is an overworked employee of the
ministry of magic his son is standing on
his own two feet and wants to follow in
his father's very big footsteps but in
doing so he puts himself in great danger
and is soon in need of help when exactly
the new Harry Potter movie is to be
released is still uncertain for now we
are waiting for official news from
Warner Brothers
when rumors started circulating some
time ago that birds of prey actress
Margot Robbie was to star in an upcoming
sixth Pirates of the Caribbean film many
fans were amazed at first glance this
was perhaps an unusual casting but as
long as the film had been a standalone
and not a cheap Jack Sparrow copy of the
opposite sex the film surely wouldn't
have performed badly in an interview
with a Vanity Fair the 32 year old spoke
about her future in the Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise and ruled out all
speculations about her role there had
been an idea for a spin-off in which she
would have played the lead role of the
interest on Disney's part seems to have
faded in the meantime so that there will
not be a collaboration after all her
clear statements in turn are creating
new rumors as to why Disney has now
backed away from the spin-off after all
due to the statements made by producer
Jerry Bruckheimer this Summer that he
and author Ted Elliott are currently
working on a script for Pirates of the
Caribbean 6. some fans now suspect that
Johnny Depp will make a comeback Depp on
the other hand has stressed several
times including trial against Amber
Heard that he will not return to Disney
thus at the moment there are no clear
answers about the future of Pirates of
the Caribbean but it could well be that
the relevant steps towards the future
will be taken in the coming months
because despite the lack of more
detailed information it does not look as
though there will be a goodbye to the
film series
there are many rumors about the upcoming
fifth Indiana Jones part especially the
return of the 80 year old Harrison Ford
who is still not quite imaginable as a
whip-wielding archaeologist is causing
some skepticism within the fan Community
up to now though there is still no first
trailer so one cannot really form an
opinion about the film yet however that
should change soon if the words of
director James Mangold are to be
believed when a fan recently asked him
when we could expect the first promo
footage mangle promised something new in
the next 30 days he didn't explicitly
mention that it would be a trailer but
given the fact that one already exists
and was shown behind closed doors at the
d23 Expo a trailer is very likely this
could also help to counter the currently
accumulating rumors that the movie is
really bad in its present form alleged
test screenings are currently taking
place where six different endings were
rated by a selected audience each is
said to have been worse than the other
with the one where Indy's goddaughter
Helena follows in his footsteps standing
out particularly badly also included was
the classic big screen death of Indiana
Jones and some sort of time travel
ending the emerging negative reports are
said to have caused some trouble behind
the scenes with Disney boss Bob chapek
internally demanding immediate reshoots
in order to still save the conclusion of
the film series director James Mangold
denies that there have been any
screenings at all which means that the
rumors should be taken with a grain of
salt for now let's first wait for the
upcoming trailer before making any
assumptions the movie is scheduled for
release on June 30th 2023
Godzilla vs Kong was certainly one of
the biggest highlights of the movie
industry last summer which had been hit
hard by the pandemic even though the
story was described as not particularly
Innovative at times there were plenty of
action sequences and many scenes that
stuck in your memory in the end in spite
of some early fighting the two giants
Godzilla and King Kong joined forces to
fight the even more dangerous
Mechagodzilla together it's all the more
fitting that the freshly revealed title
of the sequel has now been announced as
being Godzilla and Kong as for who the
upcoming villain is that the two Titans
will have to face off against well
that's still the subject of much
speculation at the moment one thing is
for sure though director Adam Wingard
wants to focus on Hollow Earth the place
of origin of Godzilla Kong and many
other Titans which is now under King
Kong's control after the last film so
far Eileen actress Rebecca Hall Bernie
actor Brian Tyree Henry and Kaylee
hoddle who embodies Gia are considered
sure returnees on the other hand it is
not entirely clear what the situation is
or regarding the two main actors Millie
Bobby Brown and Alexander Skarsgard at
least with Beauty and the Beast actor
Dan Stevens a new addition to the cast
has already been confirmed although his
exact role has not been disclosed yet
should there be any further updates on
the cast fought or the release date we
will let you know of course are you now
even more excited about the sequel
thanks to the new title and if so which
Titan do you believe could pose a real
threat to Godzilla and King Kong feel
free to post your guests in the comments
the first movie In The Chronicles of
Narnia series was released over 17 years
ago the franchise still enjoys great
popularity with the original story by
C.S Lewis being published in the 1950s
and comprising a total of seven books
three of them have already been adapted
in chronological order so there is still
enough content for at least four more
movies that is something Netflix must
have been aware of in 2018 when the
streaming service secured the movie
rights for the franchise four years
later there are now serious efforts to
also implement the films which is the
reason why there was the first news this
week following a long Hiatus according
to a report from what's on Netflix
little woman director Greta gearwig is
expected to direct not one but two The
Chronicles of Narnia movies The 39 year
old is no stranger to the film business
and is also responsible for directing
the Barbie adaptation set to debut next
year she also has several Oscar
nominations to her name so far however
due to her current involvement with the
Barbie film it will probably take some
time before where she can start work on
The Chronicles of Narnia yet her
commitment is definitely a key first
step for the production it can be
expected that they will stick close to
the books again but since the sequence
among the books is quite variable it is
impossible to say with certainty which
books gets to be adapted first anyways
we are eagerly awaiting further news
what do you guys think about gearwig's
involvement and which actors would you
love to see in the starring role let us
know in the comments down below
that's it for this week's news if you
haven't done so yet we recommend you
watch our new trailers for Puss and
Boots 2 and Magic Mike's Last Dance we
hope you enjoyed this week's Hollywood
news thanks for watching
hahaha
[Music]